كانت الرسائل المتعلقة بفيروس كورونا من
البيت الأبيض منتشرة في
كل مكان منذ
فبراير / شباط ، وكانت
غير متسقة للغاية ، فقد تسبب في تجاهل الكثير من الناس
في هذا البلد للفيروس
وعدم اتخاذ الاحتياطات اللازمة.
كيف ستحصل على الرسائل
المناسبة لجميع الأمريكيين  لإبقائهم على
اطلاع بكيفية حماية أنفسهم والآخرين بشكل صحيح
من هذا الوباء ،
ما يقوله الرؤساء مهما يستمع إليه الناس ،
سأوضح ما
يجب القيام به ،
لا يمكنني تكليف الأشخاص الذين يرتدون أقنعة
ولكن قيل لنا للتو ما
إذا كان ينبغي عليهم توقع 215 آخرين
000 قتيل بحلول كانون الثاني (يناير) ولكن إذا
ارتدينا قناعًا ، فسننقذ مئات الآلاف من
هؤلاء الأرواح من دون
فعل أي شيء سوى أنه يتعين
علينا التأكد من أننا نكشف للشعب الأمريكي
الحقيقة وأخبرهم بالحقيقة
وسأحرص على التأكد من ذلك  أود استدعاء
كل حاكم
في البلد إلى البيت الأبيض ليقول
لك إنه يجب عليك وضع التفويضات
إذا كان هناك ، وإذا لم يفعلوا ، فسوف أتصل
برؤساء البلديات في مدنهم ومدينتهم
المدن ويقولون
ضعوا تفويضات يمكنك إنقاذ الأرواح
ويجب أن نوفر للناس
معدات الحماية
التي تبدو أنيقة ، كما تعلمون ما
حدث مؤخرًا ، قال الرئيس الأمريكي
إننا لم نعد في الواقع
نوفر كتلة
للمدارس لكي تدفع لهم المدارس  أن يكون لديك القناع في
المدرسة
لأنه لم يكن حالة طوارئ وطنية ،
ما يتحدث عنه إنه أمر
غير منطقي تمامًا وانظر إلى أن هذا كله يتعلق
بشيء واحد
في سوق الأسهم لا يريد أن يرى
أي شيء
يحدث ، كل شيء يتعلق بإعادة انتخابه
الشعب
الأمريكي وهم في ورطة وإذا لم
نفعل ذلك وبالمناسبة
ناقضه مدير القرص المضغوط الخاص به
مؤخرًا
، قال إذا كنت في الواقع لا ترتدي هذا
القناع
سوى هذا القناع الذي ستقوله
من الآن وحتى يناير
حياة مائة ألف أخرى
، ولذا علينا أن نكون صادقين مع
الأمريكيين الذين هم أقوياء
يعرفونهم ، حيث قال فرانكلين روزفلت إن
الأمور تزداد سوءًا قبل أن
تتحسن وتتحسن ولكن  يجب أن
تقوم بتسوية الأمريكيين الذين يطلقون النار من
كتفهم ، لم يكن هناك وقت
لم يتمكنوا فيه من
تصعيد هذا الرئيس يجب أن يتنحى